violent weekend in chicago another one
five people killed 20 others wounded
shootings all across the city and the
youngest victim a five-month-old girl
but help may be on the way on saturday
president biden signed the most
significant federal gun control bill
in nearly three decades it's a measure
that will toughen background checks for
gun buyers under 21 years old and
provide billions of dollars for mental
health services
joining us now is the mayor of chicago
lori lightfoot mayor good morning to you
we just mentioned this new piece of
legislation how do you think it might
help your city
well first of all thank you for having
me this morning yeah another tough
weekend but what i don't want to get
lost in a shuffle is that we are down 15
in shootings and 10
and homicides but i think what this
weekend underscores is that we are
washed and illegal guns and so what the
legislation i think will help us is
there's a provision um against
trafficking and straw purchasing and we
need our federal partners to be very
vigorous and enforcing this new law
something we fought very hard for and
i'm glad finally we've seen some
positive steps in the right direction
but we need
more federal assistance in enforcing
this new law
so you just said where you're awash in
illegal guns there in chicago when you
look at crime in the city is that the
core issue is that what's behind all
these shootings is that the number one
cause
there's no question um
90 plus percent of our homicides are as
a result of illegal gunfire whether it's
gang-related but increasingly what we're
seeing is petty disputes ending in
gunfire so the fact of the matter that
our police department last year took 12
000 illegal guns off the street which is
more than new york or l.a combined tells
you the challenge that we face our
officers are heroic every single day
making the necessary stops making the
arrests um and finding these illegal
firearms but we are fighting against a
sea of them coming over the border from
other states so gun trafficking is a
significant problem for cities like
chicago new york la every major city
faces his challenge so i'm gratified
that the federal government finally has
answered the plea of victims survivors
and mayors and other municipal officials
that we need additional tools to be able
to fight against this tie of illegal
guns
you know
mayor lightfoot it's it's good to see
you i was in wilmington north carolina
and i i went to a place called true
colors brewery where they're working
with active gang members rival gang
members who are working together i've
never seen anything like it before
and what i learned there over the
weekend is that the majority of the
people in gangs it's a very small number
of people who are actually violent and
maybe we should target that is that the
experience in your city too you know you
hear gangs and it's very scary it's very
threatening and very um
and very sinister but what i learned is
that if you just target the very small
number of gang members who are violent
that that could make the difference is
that the case in chicago we start every
weekend with another bad weekend in
chicago
there's no question that we've got to be
very specific as the people who are
driving violence and gail it's not like
in the 80s and 90s in chicago where
there's an established gang hierarchy
what we see are much smaller
groupings we call them clicks but a lot
of this violence is also driven by petty
disputes among people that aren't
necessarily a fairly affiliated with the
gang
but what we need to do is be very
diligent in pushing our courts to hold
violent dangerous people in our city
accountable they can't keep getting
released back into the streets and again
i'm mindful of the constitution
everybody's presumption of innocence but
there are some people who are truly a
demonstrated danger to our community
they need to be locked up free trial and
we would see a much more significant
decrease than what we're already seeing
in our city
[Music]
you know abortion is protected under
illinois state law we had a story
earlier in this broadcast
that chances are that your city your
state in particular your state and your
city as well will be overwhelmed with
people coming in to get abortions in
your city are you prepared for that are
you anticipating that are you worried
about it
well i'm certainly worried about it i'm
worried about it for the women who are
now going to be forced to travel from
their home state to state in cities like
chicago to get the kind of reproductive
care that they should have as a right in
their home state we've already seen a
surge and a number of people coming
particularly after the court upheld the
terrible texas law and i think that that
surge is only going to increase in the
coming months and years so we are
getting ourselves prepared
i authorized an additional 500 000
to support
our reproductive health care providers
but there's more that needs to be done
we need to make sure that there are
resources for travel for lodging and for
aftercare we shouldn't be in this
circumstance but this is the reality
given what the supreme court did to
american women
on friday but we will be ready we will
remain a beacon of justice for all and
we will make sure that women who need
reproductive care are able to get it in
the city of chicago
mayor lightfoot we thank you for your
time we know you have a very full plate
in chicago thank you so much thank you
mayor
thank you for having me